my name is James friend and I was the
cinematographer on All Quiet on the
Western Front my name is Sven Goldman
I'm the editor of the film my name is
Frank Cruz I'm one of the sound
designers on this film hi I'm Kristen
Goldberg I'm the production designer on
this film hi my name is volca bertelman
and I'm the composer Frank petzold I'm
the visual effects supervisor and me and
my team were responsible for yeah
for putting it all you know I'll do all
the magic on top of it my name is like
American and I'm the hair and makeup
designer hi I'm Edward Berger and I'm
the writer director of this film All
Quiet on the Western Front and we picked
a scene for you that really became the
centerpiece of the movie it it became
the centerpiece of the movie also
because it's a centerpiece of the book
there's a scene in the book that is
utterly amazing where Paul bauma the
main character dives into a crater to
hide from attacking planes and he is
confronted with a French soldier soldier
and he stabs him 10 times and watches
him then subsequently he watches him die
and realizes that he's just another
human being that he's killing he's not
an enemy he's a human being and that he
himself has become a killing machine and
has lost his soul in a way this scene I
I I kind of don't really see it as a
scene in the film I see it as a sequence
in the film because it's it's so iconic
this sequence was particularly
challenging because obviously it's all
set in a crater we had to figure out how
to go across about two fingers and then
into the Creator and and we were cutting
it in our minds and we thought wouldn't
it be really fun to take the audience
therefore the camera with Paul barma
running across the battlefield and
jumping into the crater without an idiot
so we actually put Danny Bishop our
extraordinary um a camera operator in a
stunt wire rig he ran handheld after a
stunt man and dive headfirst into the
crater and that's how we achieved that
shot and then when the other thing we
wanted to do as well is um you know I
think Christian said wouldn't it be
great you know this is a a you know bad
time of year and all aesthetically
wouldn't be great if it was flooded so
we actually filled it about I think
after our rainfall we had about three
foot of water in it as well so it it
became a very very very tricky
logistically
um challenging set but very pleasing to
sort of work in usually you know you
want to Crank It Up you want to be
flashy shiny big and and the bigger the
better and on this project we really
wanted to be photo real and careful that
we don't distract so even starting with
the planes we uh also together with
Christian uh we wanted to be
historically correct and this time uh in
the early 1900s was just the
Breakthrough of planes so it was really
hard to figure out which planes were
even in the sky at that time and uh so
we also wanted to identify them as
French planes so it was sort of a lot of
research just going into those quick
seconds of planes flying by and then of
course with the planes you have sort of
the uh the result of the planes we have
a lot of like uh bullet hits in the
grounds just to make it a bit more to
even crank up the urgency for Paul
especially when he Peaks
um over the edge we had a beautiful I I
called it the dirt crew yeah the the
greens Department who wasn't when they
didn't do much green in this movie as
you can imagine but they were taking
care about kind of a realistic surface
in the best possible way and we had like
high resolution
photographs of 1917 1918 of the no man's
land and how those kind of layers of
Earth evolved from those craters for us
also in the technical aspect very
important kind of what kind of Earth
would give the actors kind of some
comfort even to especially in this scene
to be on top of it because of the Earth
in general was very full of clay very
sticky actually very dangerous yeah the
Earth next to the
um Soldier what Paul grabbed two stuff
into his mouth so and this of course
it's not real it was made out of like
different kind of cookies and oatmeal so
that
in case he is swallowing it it doesn't
matter so he can still like keep going
on acting for me it was just important
that every inch of the surface behind
the actors was right a white stone
particles barbed wire particles
everything should be just perfectly in
place it it it's it looks completely
random but it is it is kind of
especially towards for the surface it
was completely
thoughtfully
put there by a lot of wonderful crew
members when I saw that scene it was for
me in the beginning pretty difficult to
find out where the level of Music
um should you know how much I would
emphasis on the emotion because every
level or every inch that is too much
would take away from the realistic
acting and the the breaths and the
gurgling and you know I have everything
that is that you see and you can destroy
with music very quickly the intimacy
between
this or In This Moment which is very
rough
hey
hmm
so what I tried is I had this theme that
I used already you know in the beginning
but now it was quite melodic with a
string orchestra and we recorded this
whole music like with a full-on or 40
string orchestra and um all sorts of
sounds in there like drony sounds and
then I used the filter that cuts
everything off
that makes that was dampening all the
high end of the music I think here it
worked so nicely because we could hear
and on top of that we could hear every
breath and every little sound
that they were creating and at the same
time it was a little bit like the inner
voice of Paul boimer in a way
foreign
[Music]
our costume designer uh is such a
perfectionist she tests everything and
in this scene in particular you see how
Paul boyman takes his knife and cuts off
he takes it and the French guy thinks
he's going to kill him but in fact he
wants to open his uniform to Services
wound the pumping blood that hiker put
there so he takes a knife and she he
cuts off the buttons and these buttons
just imagine you're in this crater no
one can get to it it's watery it's hard
to work it's cold and you cut off
buttons in a tank and every time you
climb into this crater it takes a long
time for a wardrobe person to sew that
button back on and a crew of 150 people
are standing around waiting for the
person with cold fingers trying to sew a
button back on of course Lizzy had
thought of that weeks before and she
tested it she developed a system of how
to cut off a button but how to press it
back on within seconds and so she thinks
of these things technically and saying
like how how do we reset the scene
because he's going to cut off seven
buttons and I can't I can't have someone
sew on buttons for 15 minutes so she
really tested it and really helped saved
our saved our our work day otherwise it
would have taken seven days to shoot the
scene I can maybe you can tell tell us
about your makeup in our pre-production
we we were already agreeing that they
definitely all have to be dirty and
muddy and so like what kind of dirt and
mud is existing what is the color what
is the texture of so what we did like we
had a whole like bunch of different
textures of mud so luckily we also had
like you know the because here the color
in the end it became a bit greenish
yellowish and before we had like Grays
and whatever is existing and that full
Battlefield it's a bit like an elephant
skin or something you know
um yeah so that was
um a challenge on one point because also
like the the crater was so difficult to
approach where they were
um and then this one was not the only
one we had we also had like blood pumps
you know um attached to the French
soldiers jackets so that the blood is
coming pumping up like you know in
different levels and then on the other
hand it's such an emotional scene
and always disturbing basically the
actors with technical things
sometimes I I really felt bad about and
guilty so hopefully they can keep going
and stay in their you know situation
um and apart from this personal
um I never cried on set by watching a
scene
so it's
I mean the scene is great it was hard
work and so emotional that I still can
cry you know just by watching it I'm
really glad to hear that um I'm not the
that I'm not the only one who cried when
watching the scene for the first time
that there's hiker
um I remember when I watched the first
take I was truly affected and I was and
I felt uneasy for hours after watching
it and the whole scene exposes
um the brutal nature of War and the lost
Humanity in such Clarity that it was
hard to bear for me my first intention
was to let it all play out in a one take
sorry for you guys working on the
storyboard but I my impression was it
was so strong so I want to keep it like
that but um the truth is that we had
tons of great footage and we spent a lot
of time to bring out the best
performances and tickle out every detail
to make the scene as compelling as
possible
and um for me this is probably one of
the most crucial scenes in the film I am
also remember that Our intention was to
play out the scene in real time without
shortening anything so that the audience
has to experience the same emotional
development that Paul goes through and
with no way of escaping and um
and after this intense scene we felt
like that we needed a break to give a
rest and a moment of grounding I
remember that it was clear to us that we
have to embrace every little moment
every little positive moment in between
all the brutality and at the end of the
scene and the battle seems to be over
and we cut back to Paul and here we have
one of these rare moments of Hope and
when you listen really carefully you can
even hear some birds chirping in the
background it's pretty much the original
performance that's in that scene so and
that carries us through that you know
this traumatic scene and then the idea
with the birds came up
uh to create this surreal moment where
he wakes up almost like in a in a real
dream try to keep it realistic which is
the overall idea of the soundtrack of
this film really
and then yeah kind of the idea came up
to use these Swifts the the the birds
that you're hearing are mostly Swifts
which kind of have uh you know
they they spend most of their lives in
the air they rarely land and once they
land it's very difficult for them to
restart again so
it has this kind of also metaphorical
uh let's say meaning or energy in in
that short moment as well so that's kind
of the idea behind those birds in that
scene
and Felix was acting it and at some
point he heard this noise from off
camera and he was wondering what it was
and he realized he looked up and he
realized it was the operator crying
while he watched him Danny Bishop or a
cameraman from England and you have to
imagine we shot the scene this movie in
the Czech Republic
um in a country that was invaded twice
by German troops with a largely checked
crew German crew people from France
England camera crew from England Danny
Bishop from England whose grandfather
had brought him up
who would fought in the war against the
Germans who've brought him up hating the
Germans and now this English man and
this Tech and these Germans and these
French people they're all coming
together on former Battleground and sort
of filming this movie and I think it had
a profound influence on us and really
brought us also together and really
meant a lot that we were all able to
work together on this